thanks ted the silver and black are
standing tall at six
and three what a record an opportunity
to go 4-0 in the afc west sunday night
against the kc chiefs eight sports now
reporter molly sullivan caught up with
former pro bowl tackle
for the raiders lincoln kennedy for his
take on this week's matchup
hello everyone molly sullivan joined by
former raider a familiar voice lincoln
kennedy who is now upstairs with brett
musberger
as the team's color commentator for
every radio game broadcast
and lincoln chiefs week is always a big
deal but how do you best quantify this
one
it's always one of the most hated
rivalries between these two clubs
they have their own raiders a week where
they're getting all hampton we do the
same thing
with chiefs weeks i remember many years
playing against the chiefs i couldn't
stand them
didn't want to shake your hands after
the game didn't like him that's the way
it goes
but yeah this it doesn't take much to
get into this rivalry
if you're a raider player you know how
much you don't like that red and white
and they're going to come back with a
little bit of adventures because the
raiders beat them earlier this year
yeah and hey the chiefs may have won
right 12 of the last 15 meetings but the
raiders are the only team to knock off
the defending super bowl champions
this year can they do it twice it's
going to be a tough one it's going to be
a tough one because here's the thing
andy reid after a buy is 18-3 which is
an unbelievable record
he has so much success after a buy and
now look the raiders jumped on the
chiefs really early last time in week
five when they played them
they outplayed them they outcoached him
now did everything in arrowhead
and that's how they were able to beat
them you're not going to be able to
surprise them this time the chiefs are
coming for the raiders
because they know how important this
game is not only in the division
but more importantly for them to keep
pace with pittsburgh who's undefeated
yeah we just stepped out of practice
right lincoln and the good news here is
no
new positive covid 19 test results the
raiders defense has a slew of players
set to return on sunday morning
for league protocol how do they navigate
through this week lincoln you know what
things have changed since cove it
happened
they're doing more automated with
computers and and zoom calls and stuff
like that
so even though the players aren't
physically here they can take what they
call mental reps
where you're getting your instructions
and at this particular point john
and during the season molly they know
what they're doing the offense and
defense kind of run the same place over
and over again so it's not like there's
a new install
or you're missing something you just
have to have that money rep and be
patient
hey once a raider always a raider we
can't wait for sunday night lincoln
can't wait for your broadcast well i
appreciate
it it's going to be a fun one all right
we'll see you then molly sullivan
lincoln kennedy see you next time